- Thank you for coming.
My name is Yanjie Huang,
I'm a PhD candidate at East
Asian Language and Cultures,
Columbia University.
I'm primarily working on
modern content with China,
especially social and political history.
So on behalf of myself
and my fellow panelists,
I want to thank Denise, Stephanie,
and the whole CAS teams,
for providing this
wonderful opportunity for us
to share our research.
So without further ado,
I'd like to introduce our
first speaker, Gavin Healy.
So Gavin is also a PhD candidate
at Columbia University EALAC.
He works primarily on the
tourist sector in Mao's China.
- Good morning, thank you.
Thank you, Yanjie.
Thank you, Denise and Stephanie.
I'm just gonna share my screen.
So workers in China's service
sector during the Mao era
performed their jobs under
the guidance of campaigns
that attempted to define the political
and economic nature of service labor,
but service workers, or fuwuyuan,
working in hotels, restaurants,
and transportation facilities
that served overseas Chinese,
Hong Kong and Macau compatriots
and other foreign tourists
found themselves in a precarious position.
Not only were they working in an industry
outside primary production,
they were serving people
who were not necessarily
considered the people.
For these fuwuyuan,
fuwu or service was a matter
of heightened sensitivity.
They were portrayed as the
face of the new society
and were urged to perform
their work accordingly.
As fuwuyuan as on the
Guangzhou-Shenzhen railway put it,
when we do our work well, it
reflects well on the party.
When we do our work poorly,
it damages the prestige of the party.
This political element of fuwu
was cited in model worker narratives
as something that gave this non-productive
service work meaning,
yet striving for attentive service
and satisfying the
demands of foreign guests
were not always easy to reconcile
with political rhetoric that
emphasized serving the people
in a hierarchy of labor
that privileged agricultural
and industrial production.
Over the course of the 1970s,
fuwu and its relationship
to tourism, China's economy,
and the prestige of the socialist nation,
changed in many ways.
Central to this was the
redefinition of the people
that fuwuyuan would be called to serve.
As the relationship of the Chinese state
with the broader world transformed,
fuwuyuan serve new types of guests
and found themselves
navigating new conceptions
of the proper way to serve them.
Worker education campaigns
continued to emphasize
the importance of proper service attitude,
but the meaning of tourism service changed
over the course of the decade
as it was interpreted
first through the lens
of revolutionary diplomacy
and then in terms of the
modernization of the Chinese state.
In the early 1970s,
fuwuyuan a pantry restaurant in Guangzhou,
discussed how prior to
the Cultural Revolution
they pursued feudalist, capitalist,
and revisionist service,
to a small class of bourgeoisie.
With the start of the
Cultural Revolution, however,
they said they abandoned the
counter revolutionary line
of putting profit in command
and targeting both
refined and popular taste.
Henceforth, they pledged to serve dishes
and dim sum for the masses.
Other restaurants with a long
pre-revolutionary history
pledged to do the same.
In 1969, the revolutionary committee
of the Guangzhou restaurant
in a report on a struggle to
answer the fundamental question
of service for whom
likewise repudiated the
principle of targeting
both refined and popular taste.
The committee asserted that
the answer to the question
of service for whom was
service to the proletariat,
and the restaurants perpetuation
of its pre-revolutionary
legacy of refined cuisine
was revisionism.
In the past, they said,
the line in the restaurant
between refined and popular
had been quite clear.
When referring to refined and popular,
we considered the exploiting class refined
and considered the working people popular,
but now that sort of bourgeois rubbish
has been thoroughly eradicated.
But 1971 saw two seemingly unrelated
but in fact closely
connected announcements
from China's highest leadership
that brought about a shift
in the conceptualization
of tourism service labor,
and its relationship to
refined and popular tastes.
In July 1971, Mao authorized
state tourism authorities
to increase the number of foreign tourists
allowed into China,
and to permit the entry of
not just political leftists
and foreign friends,
but self-financed writers as well.
A month later, Chairman Mao's
revolutionary diplomatic line
was publicly articulated
in the People's Daily.
The revolutionary diplomatic
line was the heading given
to a broad policy of
internationalist solidarity
against imperialists,
as well as solidarity with
workers and oppressed people
living within capitalist
and imperialist nations.
Coming just weeks before the
PRC's submission to the UN,
the announcement of this
policy has been described
as part of the modernization or moderation
of earlier policies,
marking a consolidation of power
in the Foreign Ministry under Juan Lai.
Yet while this policy seems a
little more than a restatement
of by then long standing pronouncements
of Afro-Asian solidarity,
it differs in at least
one important respect.
The revolutionary diplomatic line
provided an ideological framework
to justify China's increasing engagement
with nations of the capitalist world.
While just a few years earlier,
the People's Daily criticized
the revisionism apparent
in Soviet overtures
toward Western tourists.
The revolutionary diplomatic line
separated the people from the nation,
opening up space to serve Western tourists
while continuing to publicly repudiate
the neocolonial policies
of their governments.
For China's tourism industry,
this meant a focus on
new types of customers
and new ways of
conceptualizing fuwu labor.
In December 1971,
the revolutionary committee
of pantry restaurant
enunciated the role of fuwuyuan
in the revolutionary diplomatic line.
The committee reported that
fuwuyuan must take the lead
in serving foreign guests,
must publicize Mao Zedong thought,
and be careful in carrying
out their fuwu work.
They must understand the ways
of life of foreign guests,
and adjust their services
to suit foreign guests habits and customs.
While they continued
to speak with contempt
for targeting both
refined and popular taste,
this was belied by the
attention paid to skill,
variety and refinement
when these could be linked
to the role of fuwuyuan
in revolutionary diplomacy.
When a group of Japanese
guests asked the restaurant
to prepare new varieties have been dim sum
every day for 30 days,
the chef said they consider this work
for the honor of the fatherland
and to win glory for Chairman Mao.
Their completion of this
culinary challenge, they said,
illustrated the material
abundance of socialist China.
These varieties of dim sum,
they said, exquisitely crafted,
gave the guests a deep impression
and showed how the chef's and fuwuyuan
wholeheartedly serve Chairman Mao's
revolutionary diplomatic line.
Chefs from the Overseas
Chinese Hotel in Shanghai
similarly rethought notions
such as targeting refined
and popular tastes,
and emphasis on the
importance of skilled labor
when they spoke with the pride
of the compliments they
received from guests
on their cooking.
This, they said, was
studying professional skill
for the sake of revolution.
In organizing a study group
to analyze customer's tastes
and develop new dishes,
they said they came to see more clearly
the political meaning of cooking
in the service of Chairman Mao's
revolutionary diplomatic line.
But their position at the vanguard
of the revolutionary diplomatic
line forced service workers
to confront a number of difficult issues.
As the report from the
Shanghai Mansions Hotel noted,
fuwuyuan needed to draw clear lines
between popularization and simplification,
polite eagerness and obsequiousness,
actively serving foreign
guests and fawning over them,
learning skills for the sake of revolution
and placing skill above all else,
national dignity and arrogant
great nation chauvinism,
being mindful of poise and grace
and pursuing a bourgeois manner of dress,
and careful management of the
purchase and sale of goods
versus a capitalist emphasis
on material incentives
and profit above all else.
It's evident that the lines
between these concepts
were not entirely clear to
fuwuyuan to at the time,
just as the lines between many of them
remain unclear in tourism
and other service industries
in China's post socialist world today.
Not long after the death of Mao in 1976,
fuwu came to be linked to
the four modernizations.
The four modernizations:
development of agriculture, industry,
science and technology
and national defense,
originated in a report of Juan Lai
to the National People's Congress in 1975
and were written into
the Constitution in 1978.
The skills necessary for fuwu work
in service of the four modernizations
increasingly resembled the appeal
to both refined and popular tastes
decried in the recent past.
Fuwuyuan learned more types of cuisine,
the customs and tastes of guests
from a greater variety of nations,
and more exacting standards of
table settings and etiquette.
Hotel and restaurant
workers studied new texts
like professional knowledge
for service workers,
shifting the focus of worker campaigns
from the clothes of the
70s and into the 80s
from mere valorization of fuwu labor
to professionalization of it.
Acknowledging the importance
of increased professionalization
of fuwu work.
Bo Zhuangzi, a Tsinghua news reporter
writing the People's Daily in 1979
cited projections that
over the next decade
more than 85% of new employment
would be in light industry,
handicraft and service related work.
Referring to the steelworks
in the Bao Shan district of Shanghai,
it took seven years to build
and employed 30,000 workers.
Bao noted the impossibility
of heavy industry alone
supplying the jobs necessary
for China's rapidly expanding workforce.
Bao said that with the
workforce projected to grow
by three million workers
a year from 1980 to 1985,
if heavy industry were the
sole source of new employment,
the nation would have to build
100 Bao steel works each year
to meet the demands of the labor market.
For this reason, the
service light industries
and handicraft sectors
were seen as the main path to employment
in the coming years.
Bao acknowledged that many still adhere
to what he termed the
traditional outlook in society
of looking down upon the service industry.
While pointing out that many people
did not consider a fuwu work
to be an honorable occupation
serving the people,
Bao differed from
writers in previous years
who proposed ideological campaigns
as the means to improve
service worker morale,
and instead cited only
the influence of low wages
and lack of social welfare benefits
on the morale of service workers.
Tourism and tourism related fuwu
were still occasionally linked
to the revolutionary diplomatic
line as late as 1979,
but the objectives of tourism and fuwu
had clearly expanded along
with the growing prominence
of the four modernizations
and public discourse.
Fuwu work was by this time
connected to a tourism industry
that was not merely
ancillary to political goals,
but whose development was
a goal in and of itself
as an integral part of
the four modernizations.
Urging fuwuyuan to abandon the notion
that fuwu work was menial,
instructional text for them linked fuwu
both to national development goals
and to broader definitions
of the concept of serving the people
asserting that service
to overseas Chinese,
Hong Kong and Macau
compatriots and foreign guests
is necessary for the
nation's foreign policy,
commercial intercourse,
international exchange,
and development of tourism industry,
all of which are in service,
socialist construction,
and service to the people.
From the 12th Party Congress in 1982,
the four modernizations evolved
to new forms of political
and economic planning.
In respect of the tourism industry,
Vice Premier Zhou Enlai
set forth the principle
of friendship first,
with economic benefits.
As one state tourism industry
researcher interpreted it,
friendship first, with economic benefits
reflected not the primacy
of one of these aspects
of tourism over the other,
but the intrinsic, unified relationship
of the political and the economic.
Tourism, he said, was an activity
with economic attributes,
but it also carried political meaning
in its role and acquisition
of advanced technology
and management experience from abroad
and in it's promotion of
understanding and friendship
between the people of China
and the peoples of the world.
As the director of the Shanghai
tourism training school
put it in 1983,
the goal set up in the tourism policy
of friendship first,
with economic benefits
was to reap bumper harvests in
both politics and economics.
This was an acknowledgment, he said,
that in the past it was
wrong to settle accounts
in political terms alone
without considering economics,
but to pursue economic benefits
alone and ignore politics,
to ignore the political mission
of China's tourism industry
would harm the reputation
of China's tourism
and the reputation of the nation itself.
Yet the roots of these
practical and discursive shifts
came much earlier,
and the announcement of Chairman Mao's
revolutionary diplomatic line in 1971
set the stage for the
commercial revolution
that would be carried out
in China's tourism service industry
over the course of the 1970s and beyond.
Thank you.
- Thank you, Gavin.
So our second speaker, Peter E. Hamilton,
is a system professor at
Trinity College Dublin.
He primarily works on
transnational networks
in between Mainland
China, Hong Kong and U.S.,
I think his first book has just come out,
congratulations, Peter,
and he's currently
working on his new project
on origins of business schools in China.
So, Peter, please.
- I'll go ahead and share my screen.
Okay.
I'd like to thank Yanjie Huang
for spearheading this panel,
all my fellow panelists for
sharing their excellent papers,
and both Denise Ho and the whole council
on East Asian studies for
sponsoring this virtual panel.
With professional
development opportunities
curtailed right now,
I really thank you for your
leadership and generosity.
In 1991, nine universities
inaugurated China's first
permanent MBA programs.
By 2006, there would be 100
such programs in the PRC,
and 236 by 2015.
On one level,
this explosive growth
testifies to a long history
of Chinese engagement with the discourse
of scientific management
over the 20th century,
which is the subject
of my new book project.
And this engagement took root
in the early republican era
through transnational
circulations of knowledge,
but had been derailed amid
the Great Leap Forward.
Viewed in this light,
the revival of management education
represented a return to modernizing
and developmentalist practices
from before the Mao era.
On another level, though,
MBA programs seem to pose a paradox.
Although PRC officials have
long considered education
to be a politically sensitive area,
these programs were heavily
based on U.S. models
and often established in partnership
with American universities,
and even with funding
from elite us educated overseas Chinese.
In this light, the revival
of management education
looked a lot like state sanctioned
foreign and capitalist influence.
Many scholars have examined
the role of foreign expertise
in the reform era
and the evolution of
grassroots management practices
in factories and firms,
but historians have not really examined
the simultaneous revival
of management education
as a key component of
China's economic reforms.
And so this paper
attempts to fill that gap
and contribute to both
scholarship on the reform era
and Sino-U.S. relations.
And so first, I will
discuss several initiatives
to revive management
education in the early 1980s
and the entwined discourse
of management as a science,
and then I will discuss the transformation
of management education
at Tsinghua and Fudan
over the late 1980s and 1990s,
which had a huge impact
on all subsequent Chinese MBA programs.
So in the cultural revolutions wake,
a consistent theme and logic
among the diverse reformers
was refocusing the PRC's
industrial management practices
around new ideals of
efficiency and science.
As a result, while scholars have studied
the origins and debate of
macro economic policy shifts,
a more mundane but vital
aspect of this new era
was simply retraining ordinary
managers in both the party
and throughout state owned enterprises
in more professional
notions of management.
As a result, there was a
spate of ensuing initiatives
in the early 1980s and
government added industry
to research management science,
and retrain ordinary cadres
and managers in its ways.
Can't really go into very many,
but one that is illustrative
was launched by the first
ministry of machine building
or Yijibu,
and the Yijibu was one of
the single largest pieces
in the PRC's civilian
industrial sector then,
and also ran its own system of colleges.
As such, the Yijibu had a vast
and really unwieldy
portfolio of responsibilities
that could use more efficient
and better management.
As such, with political backing
from Bo Yibo and Liao Chengzhi,
in the fall of 1978 the Yijibu
hired a young MIT doctoral student
who's studying on exchange in
Beijing named Joseph Battat
to launch program in systems engineering.
Fluent in Mandarin and versed
in the political rhetoric,
Battat was able to tour
the Yijibu factories,
use his networks to purchase
materials and hire faculty,
and launch this program
at the Shanghai Institute
of Mechanical Engineering
in early 1979.
And while termed systems engineering,
in Battat's own words it was quote,
an MBA program in all but name
lacking only for instruction in finance.
Another set of management
science initiatives
emanated from the new Chinese
Academy of Social Sciences
and its Institute of Industrial Economics.
These included research
projects, a postgraduate program,
and even a national
distance learning course
known as the periodical university.
The Institute of Industrial Economics
also formed the Chinese Association
of Industrial Enterprise
Management Education in 1979,
which sponsored the
writing and publication
of the first management textbook
published since the Cultural Revolution.
Written between March
1979 and August 1980,
by 27 economists and
scholars of management,
the textbook industrial
enterprise management
is really fascinating
on a number of levels.
As well as a statement
about the revival of these disciplines,
this textbook also sought to
reconcile two key concepts:
Chinese socialism and
scientific management.
In very simple and direct language,
the texts repeatedly asserted
the future state owned enterprise managers
must understand quote,
that enterprise management is a science
and that the improvement of
China's management service
was quote, a necessary condition
for socialist modernization.
Simultaneously, the text
studiously avoided bourgeois terms
such as profit,
and even marshaled Marx himself
to declare that large scale production
would quote, inevitably
produce supervisory labor
and command labor.
And chapter one in particular
does really heavy ideological lifting
to establish the crucial theoretical basis
for the PRC to borrow safely
from capitalist management practices.
In the 1950s, Soviet
and PRC management texts
always stressed that
economics was subordinate
to party leadership,
which is an obviously unscientific preset.
Now, chapter one put
forth an innovative theory
of management's dual
nature, or shuangchong xing.
In this theory,
which is visualized here
in this amazing chart
that I'm happy to discuss
further than the Q&A,
the writing group argued that capitalist
and socialist systems of management
had but one common nature, or gong xing,
when it came to honing evermore
efficient forces of production
based on facts, experience and reason.
Thus in this realm, which is
on the left side of this chart,
Chinese management could learn
from capitalist management
to boost productivity, drive innovation,
and deliver greater material rewards.
When it came to the social
relations of production
on the right of the chart,
capitalist and socialist
systems of management
had distinct individual natures or gexing,
that must be safeguarded.
Here, there would be no borrowing
and this separation would ensure
that learning from capitalist methods
did not become exploitation.
In particular, the texts
stressed the maintenance
of state ownership as crucial insurance
to preserve the correct social
relations of production.
And this creative justification
for injecting capitalist
management into Chinese socialism
encapsulates the intellectual work
that was being done by reformists,
particularly these academics
in the early 1980s,
who repeatedly addressed the
Cultural Revolution head on,
acknowledging that quote,
extreme leftism in enterprise management
had caused, quote,
serious harm to the development
of management science
in our country.
In turn, the text insisted
that now there would be no conflict
between scientific
management and party policies
since in quote, normal times,
party policies and state planning
always appeared to objective laws.
And so if this isn't clear,
the textbook is really trying
to reinvigorate management science
as an intellectual
bulwark against any return
to the economic fantasies of the Mao era.
Simultaneously, the dual nature theory
seems to safely reassure everyone
that there would be no changes
to the ownership of state firms.
And so in short, the inevitable
conclusion of the textbook
was not just that scientific management
and Chinese socialism are compatible,
but rather that they
were an essential pairing
to achieve the four modernizations
and thus the textbook make
very explicit and concrete
some of the precise
intellectual work necessary
to reconcile socialist ideologies
and increasingly capitalist practices.
So with the time remaining
I want to briefly highlight
how these kinds of initial efforts
to revive management education
on scientific grounds
evolved toward American style
MBA programs in the 1990s.
And the first formal MBA
program was established in 1984
at the Dalian University of Technology
in partnership with SUNY.
But this program did not last very long,
and unfortunately, I don't yet know why
'cause that research has been
derailed by the pandemic.
Future premier Zhu Rongji
was a driving force though
in establishing Tsinghua School
of Economics and Management
also in 1984,
and he spoke often
throughout the late 1980s
of the urgent need to improve
China's management standards
through retraining.
Yet as Zhu's political career accelerated,
the actual administration of Tsinghua SEM
largely fell to his
colleague, Zhao Chunjun.
In 1986, Tsinghua employed
Zhao as the deputy dean,
and like Zhu, Zhao was an
electrical engineer by training
who had now pivoted towards
systems engineering,
emphasizing again the
scientific aspirations
behind the revival of management.
Yet in reality,
management education at
every major PRC university
remains small, under resourced,
and very intellectually constrained.
At both Tsinghua and Fudan,
there was little to no dedicated space,
a faculty of primarily
mathematicians and engineers,
and teaching methods
that consisted primarily
of three hour lectures.
And so it was resolved by the late 1980s,
both Zhu Rongji and Fudan Zhenlin,
were increasingly convinced of the need
for an intellectual
international partnership,
particularly with top
U.S. business schools.
As seen through Battat's program,
MIT had long been engaged in
such endeavors in the region,
and was very interested in expanding
and was doing so throughout
the late 1980s and early 1990s.
And by 1994, Sloan's leaders had decided
that Tsinghua and Fudan were
the most promising institutions
in the PRC for a potential partnership
and dispatched a team under
Associate Dean Alan White,
to investigate the two schools
to try to decide between them.
And even though there were
skeptics on both sides,
the enthusiastic supportive scholars
such as physicist and
MIT graduate, Xie Xide,
reportedly helped convince Sloan
to actually partner with both institutions
and the three schools signed
a memorandum of understanding
in June 1995.
And for Fudan and
Tsinghua the primary goals
of MIT China Management Education Project
were, quote, faculty development
and the development of
cutting edge curricula
for MBA students who will
operate internationally.
This cutting edge curricula
is particularly important
in marking the transition away
from overly quantitative
and scientific approaches
and toward one unthinkable courses
and things such as communications,
marketing, leadership,
and other subjects.
And this is primarily
mapping on to China's drive
towards the socialist market economy
and perhaps the justifications
of things like the dual
nature theory allowed them,
the leaders of the three schools,
to put the political
differences between them aside.
And so the memorandum of
understanding makes no mention
of any particular political conflicts
except noting a few areas
that we put off limits
such as industrial relations.
This ability to ignore
politics was also enabled
by where the funding came from,
primarily from elite
MIT alumni in Hong Kong,
a particular link with the
book that just came out,
Chinese American executive Shirley Young
had warned MIT against accepting any funds
from the Chinese government,
and instead Alan White
have recruited tycoons
such as these four to
bankroll this program.
These U.S. educated Hong Kong elites
also joined us projects advisory board
and pushed the MIT China project
to focus on sponsoring
trans-Pacific educational circulations.
From the fall of 1996,
Fudan and Tsinghua dean's began
dispatching junior scholars
to Cambridge for a term or a year
as international faculty fellows.
And these sponsored exchanges
allowed Chinese professors
to improve their English,
studied MBA methodologies,
and prepared to teach many
of the exact same materials
in their own classrooms.
Since I'm running out of time,
I will wrap up by
highlighting just two aspects
of the ensuing knowledge
circulations here.
First, this opportunity
was essentially mandatory
for Chinese faculty,
and often included
wholesale career change.
For example, June Qian Xiaojun
made a huge disciplinary
shift from applied mathematics
to managerial communications.
She commented, quote,
I was in my second year
of teaching statistics
when Dean Zhao asked me to learn
to teach managerial communications.
I wondered about taking on a subject
so far from my original field.
He said that no one at Tsinghua
knew what of course and
communications should be,
but that MIT Sloan placed
great importance on it.
The course needed to be taught in English
and he thought I could do this
if I observed how it
was taught at MIT Sloan.
In essence, Qian's chance fluent English
determines Xiao's decision
to reroute her entire career.
After her time at MIT in fall 1997,
Qian not only returned to
teach managerial communications
from the same textbook,
but also became a national leader
in developing this field
across Chinese universities.
Indeed, second and finally,
the knowledge produced
by the MIT partnership
was rapidly disseminated
throughout all Chinese MBA programs.
In fall 1994, the State Council
and the Ministry of Education
approved the formation
of the national MBA education
supervisory committee
with Dean Zhao as its first chair.
And the participants
basically, the leaders of this,
were worried that the rapid expansion
of MBA programs in China
would undermine their quality
and thus the new national committee
created a mandatory core MBA curriculum,
in which quote, roughly
half the nationally mandated
or recommended core courses
aligned closely with,
or are virtually identical
to the MIT Sloan courses.
And so for example in 2005,
the committee began to
require all MBA programs
to teach managerial communications,
June Qian then compiled the
recommended course outline book
and to this day teaches an annual seminar
to train other scholars in
the relevant case studies.
And another example I won't go into
but can talk about is
the course in textbook
"Data, Models, and Decisions".
And so to wrap up this
paper and presentation,
map out a two part transition
in Chinese management
education and ideologies
over the 1980s and 1990s,
first away from Cultural
Revolution rhetoric
and towards scientific ideals,
and then toward American
models MBA programs
through partnership with MIT.
These shifts highlight that senior leaders
were thinking very actively
about management education
as part of the economic reforms,
and the transnational networks and actors
had real influence in shaping
the content and quality
of Chinese higher education,
at least in this realm.
Perhaps most importantly,
focusing on management education
helps to illuminate and
make more he makes sense
of the intellectual work
behind the reform era's
blending of socialist ideologies
and capitalist practices.
Thank you.
- Thank you, Peter.
So our third speaker is Adam Frost.
Adam is a PhD candidate
in history department, Harvard University
and he works primarily on entrepreneurship
in socialist China.
Adam, please.
- [Adam] Hello, great talks.
Yeah, so in my talk I'm
gonna be doing something
a little different,
and I am going to be showing how I study
this period from a more kind
of bottom up perspective.
So my research has been
motivated by what I see
is the central puzzle
of modern Chinese economic development,
namely, how is it that after three decades
of violently suppressing capitalism,
the Chinese state was able
to transform its economy
virtually overnight
into this engine dynamic
and sustained growth.
I mean, according to the prevailing view
of Chinese development,
prior to reform and opening up,
the Chinese state presided
over a quote, unquote,
cellular economy,
with highly atomized
production and exchange,
society was divided up
into these self-reliant
administrative units
like the commune, the city,
labor markets were abolished,
and the state erected
all kinds of barriers
to mobility and exchange
such as the household registration system.
And as the China sociologist, Marty Whyte,
very recently put it in
terms of the movement
of people, goods, and services,
China in 1978, at the beginning
of reform and opening up,
was a less integrated
economy than in 1949.
But here's the problem as I see it.
If the Chinese socialist economy
were truly atomized as late as 1978,
whence came the sudden and
powerful entrepreneurial impulse?
So in my dissertation and
in this paper in particular,
I develop and analyze original data sets
to argue that socialist China
was not, in fact, void of
entrepreneurial activity.
I show that beneath the veneer
of the formal socialist economy,
there is this dynamic
realm of economic activity
where entrepreneurs are
actively filling in holes,
profiting from inefficiencies
in the planned economy,
and more generally,
just making things work,
and specifically, I use
new empirical evidence
that I myself created or assembled
to advance the following
three propositions:
I argue that the Chinese socialist state
was never that successful
in suppressing private
entrepreneurial activity,
that entrepreneurship
under Chinese socialism
was both greater in scale and scope
than previous scholarship
would lead us to believe,
and that the central and local
governments were not unified
in their efforts to enforce
formal socialist institutions
and suppress private activity.
Sorry here.
So the reason why existing scholarship
has sort of gotten mischaracterized,
socialist China, I think, has
to do with the overreliance
on high level policy documents
and official statistics.
I mean, these sources at best
suffer from extreme biases,
and at worst are really political fictions
that are meant to advance state power.
So in order to overcome the
limitations of these sources,
I instead turn to grassroots data.
And to explain how I'm doing this,
let me tell you a quick story.
So one day I was doing
research in the city of Yiwu
and I was visiting a flea
market on the outskirts of town.
And while walking from stall to stall
and I was kind of digging through
different kinds of socialist
memorabilia, Mao badges,
and ration coupons and stuff like that,
I came across this big stack
of brown jacketed dossiers.
So I pick up the folder on top of the pile
and I begin flipping through the contents
and inside were government reports
written during the Cultural
Revolution on black markets,
underground factories,
and other quote, unquote,
spontaneous capitalist activities.
So I got really excited
when I saw these documents
and I bought them all
without haggling very much,
and I asked the vendor if he had more
so he shared with me his WeChat info
and then he invited me back
to his home in Angwhei.
So the next week I went to his home
at this little apartment
at the edge of town,
and inside the apartment were
just pillars of documents
stacked from floor to ceiling,
except for this tiny
space in the living room
that had been carved out for a tea table.
The rest of the apartment was chock full
of historical materials,
including former government archives
still in their brown paper jackets.
So I ended up procuring
some of these materials
and for the next five years,
I networked with communities
of document merchants
from whom I assembled
thousands of documents
related to underground
capitalism and socialist China.
So in the course of
procuring these documents,
I was fortunate enough to come by
two exceptionally complete collections
of more than 2500 cases
of so called speculation and
profiteering, touji he baoli,
prosecuted by two local
administrations in China.
So here's just a picture
of some of the documents
that belong to that collection,
and each case focuses on the investigation
of people like these men
who were arrested for
engaging in various types
of illicit commerce and
underground production,
in this case, they're
selling coupons and things,
ration coupons.
So the cases involved all manner of goods
from poached furs, to
smuggled wristwatches,
to arms and munitions,
and most importantly for me
and the purposes of my work,
most included some kind
of case summary like this
that outline the type
of illicit activities,
where and when they occurred,
and what types of goods were involved.
Now, in addition to
examining many of these cases
in meticulous detail,
I also try to view them from a distance,
I abstract their contents into data
and then I use this data to
build micro economic data sets.
So to explain how let
me use this case summary
as a quick illustration.
So the case summaries provide
all types of information
that are useful to generate data.
So in the first line of text here,
we are told that the prosecuting
individual is a male,
56 years of age, born into
a poor peasant household,
and he's a member of
the Bai Peoples Commune.
So we can code this information
into categories like
gender, age, class status,
and institutional affiliation.
From the second paragraph,
we learn that the individual
between the years of 1973 and 1976
sold six head of cow
for a total of 1127 RMB
so we can similarly code this data.
And then finally in the third paragraph,
we learn that he was punished
with a fine of 500 RMB.
So from this type of information,
we can derive the proportional
level of punishment.
So we can take that 500 RMB
divided by the total case value, 1127.
So you get the economic fine
in this case was equal to 44%
of the total reported case value.
And although it's not in this example,
many cases also include information
about the origin and terminus
of illicit economic activity
that we can code into geospatial data.
So over the course of almost two years
I went through all 2600
cases in my data set,
this particular data set,
and manually coded their contents
into something that looks like this
and use them to create what I believe
are the largest data sets
on illicit economic
activity in socialist China.
There were all sorts of
challenges in this process
dealing with missing
data, incomplete data,
and I won't go into that here
but I'm happy to talk
more about that in the Q&A
if anyone's interested.
So what does the data tell us?
First, the data set reveals
something about the scale
of these illicit economic activities.
If we look at the summary statistics
for the two counties that
I have analyzed here,
we find that the mean value of goods
described in the cases was on
the order of three to 500 RMB.
Moreover, the average amount
of cash seized in the cases
was about 100 RMB,
so these are pretty huge
numbers for this period.
To put those into perspective,
the mean annual consumption
of a rural worker
was about 100 RMB a year,
and the annual disposable
income of urban work,
I mean, was really a lot lower,
still around 10 to 20 RMB per year.
So in other words, there's a lot of cash
flowing in this illicit economy
and the mean entrepreneur was not
a farmer selling a couple
of chickens at the market.
I mean, it's a specialized
producer a trader
who is dealing in quantities of goods
whose value represent
multiple years of consumption
of the mean worker.
So the data set also provides
insight into the spatial scope
of entrepreneurial activity.
So here, I represented
the spatial distribution
of network connections
for the two counties
in this particular dataset.
As we can see, the illicit
activity do not just occur
within socialist administrative units,
but they go across them.
So there's a distinguishable core cluster
from these two counties
that reaches out to
more distal connections,
places as far away as Sichuan in the West
and Heilongjiang in the north.
And if we zoom in on the core cluster,
we find that the network
extending from these two counties
completely crosses provincial lines
and in no way really
conforms to prefectural
or provincial boundaries.
And just impressionistically
if we compare the results
of this core cluster
to say William Skinner's
classical delineation
of physiographical macro regions,
we find that the area of illicit networks
that I've mapped out in these two counties
conforms really well to the
Lower Yangzi a macro region.
So from this type of spatial evidence,
we can at least begin to
infer that economic activity
was probably shaped more
by topographical features
and traditional merchant networks
than by socialist
administrative boundaries.
More work will need to be done here though
as I add in more counties
from different provinces
into my data set.
But finally, and most
interestingly, I think,
the data reveals that local governments
did not faithfully execute
central government directives
for suppressing private
entrepreneurial activity.
So in the 1960s, the central
government directives
basically stated that all goods
acquired through private
illicit activities
should be seized by government agencies,
and that the severity of punishment
for the convicted
speculators and profiteers
should scale in accordance
with the aggregate value
of their illicit activity.
In other words, the bigger the activity,
the bigger the punishment.
However, what we find in the data
is that the patterns of punishment
were almost exactly the opposite.
So if we divide the cases into
temporal cohorts like this,
as I've done here,
we noticed two really surprising things.
First, we see that in the
sample only a handful of people
received any form of
extra monetary punishment.
In other words, when
individuals were caught
engaging illicit activities,
they were really only punished
by and large with fines.
Very few people were sent
to jail, sent to labor camp,
or even like publicly criticized,
and this was true
even during the Cultural
Revolution period.
Second, and equally surprising,
even when entrepreneurs were punished
with seizures and fines,
the majority of goods were
actually returned to them
so you can see that in the
column percent returned.
In every cohort, we have
more than half the goods,
half the value of the goods being returned
to the entrepreneurs.
So what's going on here?
And if you read through the
individual cases as I've done,
you start coming across
the phrase yi gei ding
de jiage caigou a lie
which literally means to
procure at a given price,
turn into a price and procure it.
And so what was happening was
that instead of seizing goods
from entrepreneurs outright,
government officials were
forcibly procuring them
at low prices.
But in effect, this meant
that the local governments
were taxing the goods
and then entrepreneurs were
being left with enough capital
to effectively continue
their private pursuits.
If we dig deeper into the data,
we find that the size of seizure and fines
was actually inversely proportional
to the total value of
illicit economic activity.
In other words, the bigger the activity,
the lighter the punishment,
and this directly contravenes
those central directives,
and this was true in both of
my observed administrations.
Moreover, punishments were not uniform
as they were supposed to be.
If you divide up the types of punishments
based on various factors
as I've done here,
we find that the illicit
exchange of ration coupons
was far more likely to
be dealt with severely
than the illicit exchange
of agricultural products
or consumer goods.
So this demonstrates that officials
were being calculative and selective
in their enforcement practices,
they chose what types
of activities to punish
and they chose which ones to tolerate.
And based on my individual cases,
I really take this reading
of these individual cases,
I take this to mean that local officials
were really interested
in protecting activities
that they viewed as being
productive in the local economy
while punishing those such
as ration coupon trading
that they thought were really unproductive
and frustrated their efforts
to move around resources.
So, collectively, my new data, I think,
demonstrates that elicit
entrepreneurial activity
was a lot bigger and
a lot more permissible
than previous scholarship suggests.
While formal economic institutions
during the socialist era
may have been explicitly designed
to divide and control the economy,
socialist entrepreneurs
found all kinds of ways
to effectively circumvent
these institutions
and help facilitate flows of
capital, labor, and knowledge,
and in doing so that even
gradually won the tacit support
of local officials.
So that was a very rough
kind of synopsis of the paper
that I'm currently working on.
I'm happy to go into detail later
on anything that you
find more interesting,
but I hope this at least gives
a flavor of how the sources
and the methods that I'm
bringing to the table here
are offering a different
vantage from which to understand
socialist economic practice.
Thank you very much.
- Thank you, Adam.
So the last presentation is
mine so where's my script.
So my paper today sort of look at
very similar question as Adam's,
So I'm looking at the origins
of the Xiakang society
to kind of show the kind of ideology
that came after the decline of
Maoism in contemporary China.
I'm looking at the burst
of the Xiakang society
as a socioeconomic product
of the Maoist Cultural Revolution.
So the central question of this paper is
why did China abruptly
turn away from communism
in the late 1970s and
never really turned back?
What was the post-socialist new order?
So what is the nature
of this Xiakang society
that came after the communist order?
And the why or the new order so durable,
so even today Xi Jinping
he will still talking about
how China has fulfilled the primary goal
of the Xiakang society.
So the basic question is
about the historical dynamics
that leads to the decline of communism
and the rise of the Xiakang society.
Previous scholarship have talked about it
from a variety of perspectives
like elite politics,
how the Cultural Revolution
actually led to the downfall
of communist system, the
rise of technocratic elites,
China's shifting geopolitical
strategies in the Cold War,
and as Adam shows, a bottom-up
source of entrepreneurship
even during a Maoist era.
So the perspective that
I'm proposing to examine is
the dynamics where everyday life.
So what kind of everyday
life dynamics were there?
In particular, I'm looking
at family-state relations
in urban China.
So to understand family-state relationship
in the Maoist China,
I think is pivotal to
conceptualize this period
as a period of what I call
a period of revolutionary austerity.
So basically, I'm talking about
this long period from 1962
so basically after the
Great Leap Forward failure
to the start of reform
as so called period of
revolutionary austerity.
So by revolution austerity
basically means state-family
redistribution of income
under the command economy.
So basically, becomes state
were forcefully redistributing
income, national income,
from the livelihood and
reproduction of urban household
to strategies like defense,
and self fund constructions
and diplomatic spendings.
So why was this austerity
a revolutionary austerity?
First because it's a direct
result of the fiscal impact
of the Great Leap Forward
and the Cultural Revolution,
and then because the whole
mobilization of urban families
to sacrifice for state
political objectives
were mobilized and sustained
consistently by Cold War
and ideological mobilizations,
such as anti-revisionism and
the proletarian consolidation
and the Cultural Revolution.
So I divided into two phase,
the first phase was basically
before the establishment
of urban communes in 1968
and second phase was basically the face
of the sent-down movement.
So the key measures of these austerities,
I summarized it as four.
So first, there is a
major urban wage freeze,
which basically freeze
urban wage of all levels
between 1963 and 1977,
there was massive laying off
and the job freeze for two periods,
first, as a direct
result of credit default
and then during the first phase
of the Cultural Revolution.
And then there was massive rustication
sending down people from the
cities to the countryside,
first as a downsizing in the early 60s
and then as the sent-down
movement in the 70s,
and fourthly, the birth control
which was introduced into urban China
basically in the middle 60s.
So all those measures
were forcefully imposed
on the urban households
so as to measure to save state spending
livelihood and reproduction.
So basically the physical rationales
of the revolution austerity
we can analyze it into
like two components,
the first component was economic cost.
So basically, the state
was trying to force up
on the urban household economic costs
of failed political movement.
First is definitely the Great Leap Forward
which cost up to 60%
of the budget in 1961,
and then during the early
phase of Cultural Revolution,
again, because of the
chaos that were produced
in the first phase of Cultural Revolution,
they were a lot of budgets
revenue amount to 25%
in the year between 1966 and 1968.
And then there was also the
more durable economic costs
of China's Cold War mobilizations,
especially during the 1970s
when China was spending big amount
on funding revolutionary
programs worldwide,
on building up his military
in anticipation of a huge
confrontation of the Soviet Union
and building up The Third Front.
So all those spending,
if you add together,
it takes up almost half of the
national budget in the 1970s.
So this is a graph that tells us a bit
about the impact of
the political movement.
So these are the revenues.
So we can see that there was a big jump,
first during the Great Leap
Forward and then a sharp fall,
and then there is a bit of
recovery in the early 60s
and then followed up another big fall
in the Cultural Revolution.
And this is the share of military budget
in the national budget and GDP.
So we can see that after
the end of the war,
it has been maintained at a
very high level of over 15%
during much of his time,
and then declined gradually
force into like five
or 6% in the early 60s.
But most importantly, I think,
we need to understand impact
in terms of the supply of urban jobs
because in common economy,
urban jobs means a almost
a life long employment
with a small basket of social security,
and with guaranteed promotion of incomes
as the workers get promoted
on their skill level.
So, basically, we can see that
after the Great Leap Forward,
there's a sharp fall marked by
the great the mass downsizing
of urban workers to the countryside.
And then again in the
late 60s and early 70s,
there was another big fall.
So, basically, there was a
huge shortfall of urban jobs
during this period,
especially the early period,
early period of the austerity,
that only began to recover
a bit in the middle 70s.
But talking about the austerity
as this huge, big political
and economic project,
we can perhaps create sent-down movement
at the center of this whole process,
because it epitomized the whole process
in all its dimensions.
So the sent-down policy in Shanghai,
if we compare the scale
is about five to 8%
of national total.
So basically, Shanghai was
where there's a non policy
was most rigorously implemented.
In terms of fiscal impact
is a huge reduction
in wage spending for the government.
So basically, the
government can save huge,
according to my estimation, 400 million,
or 50% of the revenue
Shanghai during the 70s
by just sending down employable workers,
young student and used to the countryside
so they need to feed themselves.
It was also a part of the
Continuous Revolution,
first as a continuation of
Pre-1949 CCP economic programs,
like the grid construction
programs in Yangon.
Is those are measures of
flattened urban rural wage gaps
and it was measured to
preempt the bourgeoisization
of the youth.
And finally, it can also be viewed
in the context of Cold
War as a war preparation
against imperial powers,
especially Soviet Union,
as a relocation of
manpower from the cities
in anticipation of an air strike
or other major war movement,
and also, as an effort to staff
the 12 huge frontier military farmers
that are built up in the 1960s and 70s
along China's Northwest,
Southwest, and Northeast frontiers.
So these are the kind of slogans they used
to inspire youth to
sacrifice for the country
by going down to the countryside.
So if we look at this issue
from families perspective,
then we can find that sent-down movement
at least add three types
of costs on the families,
economic cost, first as
a cost of resettlement,
because the family need to
afford for the basic equipment
and sometimes even
foodstuff for the youngsters
to go to the countryside.
But more important,
it is the cost comes up as a future loss,
the loss of future urban job income
because they basically lost
their guaranteed employment
in big cities.
And then it comes as emotional cost
first as a pure pain of family separation,
and then induced economic strains
and the emotional cost at home.
And lastly, it also came at
a longer reproductive cost
because by separating the families,
separating the generations,
there's definitely a delay
in marriage and childbirth
due to all sorts of uncertainties.
So the case I'm presenting
today is the Hua family,
basically a Hua Zhongmin family
that I found really interesting
from the Fudan Center
of Contemporary China
Social Life Data and Research
is one of the seven letter collections
that I mobilized for
this research project,
but the Hua family letter
came as really interesting
because it represents Hua
Zhongmin's own letters
to his daughters
and other relatives during
this whole austerity period
between the middle 60s to the late 70s.
And Hua was actually
a very average worker,
level four on skill level
and working and earning
around 80 grand per month
and his single breadwinner was his wife,
been laid-off from the
neighborhood production teams
after the Great Leap Forward,
and then they had to
feed about four children,
two of them were grown up daughters
who were sent down to the countryside
one Hua Zhongmin and another Ghiangshi
in the late 1960s and early 70s.
So these letters reflect
it on the everyday
political and economic
concerns of the family
and it also reflect the kind
of grassroots ideologies
that we wanted then as the
basis of this Xiaokang society.
So basically, from this
compilation of data
from the letters,
we can see how the sent-down movement
during the first period of two years
had a huge impact on family finance,
whereas the income
because of the wage freeze
was stationary at 85 grand per month.
They had afford like 400 grand
just to sent-down their
$2 in the first two years,
so that's about five months income
and also it represents
almost five to six years
of the savings.
So basically, they depleted the savings
in order to just afford the initial stage
of sent-down movement,
and beyond that they need to borrow
actually from the families
and also the work unit.
So this is the kind of
family support networks
where they collected the basic resources
for the sent-down of the
two eldest daughters.
So basically, they are
relying very heavily
on both the work unit,
which acted more like a
precautionary saving institutions,
and moreover, they were
relying on the the families,
the relatives, especially
the parents in laws.
So how did Hua family situation
compare to other families?
I selected like five families
from this archive of workers
in the Shanghai United Front department.
So these are five workers who
receive subsidies in 1973.
And in fact, if we compare the situations
between Huatining all those five workers,
their situation was pretty similar.
They all have like at least
one children being sent down
and they were all like families,
really just one breadwinner
and you can see that but middle 70s
they were basically barely
surviving under a meager income.
This is their capita income,
which is actually below the
stipulated average of 20 grand,
and sometimes even below the 50 grand
that was these basics
livelihood subsidy income.
But the impact of the sent-down movement
and austerity measures
goes beyond just purely economic impact,
it also impacted family
reproductive strategies.
So basically, if Hua had his daughters,
two of his daughters
actually delay the marriage,
eventually married in Jeannine,
but without ever returning
back to Shanghai until 1976.
So basically, if we calculate
the whole family's spendings
and their reproductive strategies,
then we can see that eventually by 1975,
there were families economic
situations actually improved
because there were fewer
children being born,
almost no children being
born in the early 1970s
and the family size just gets smaller.
So if you compare to the
whole situation in Shanghai,
then Hua family situation
was actually quite typical
because if you compare the whole
situation in the early 60s,
Shanghai was a economy
with very high dependency ratio of 73.7,
the fertility rate was almost four,
and Engel coefficient was at 58.
But by the late 70s,
the dependency rate had fallen 1.5
and it's actually kept falling
to 1.1 in the early 80s,
but fertility rate was reduced to 1.2
and Engel coefficient has
improved to about just 32.
So basically what happened
to the mindset of the people out there?
So after years of those
economic frustrations
and all those burdens,
Hua Zhongmin began to realize
that what was the cost
of the whole problem
and to become the articulate those issues
with his own friends.
So as the economy was weak,
he was talking about how economy
and also his family economy
they failed in government
they simply led people to bear the burden.
The send-dow movement will leave
me in debt for eight years,
I will try to pay off the
outstanding debt in 1976,
rebuild my family economy
and build a better-off
family, xiaokang zhijia.
So xiaokang zhijia first appeared
in all the letter says I have exempt
at the sort of articulation of
a new vision of the families.
But more importantly,
it appears also in
grassroots opinion surveys.
So if you look at survey of materials,
80% of the survey sent-down used in 1978
articulate that they felt a
sense of economic victimhood
during this sent-down era.
About 75 young workers
who were surveyed in 1980s
during the Shanghai department
of propaganda survey
articulated that they
regarded family welfare
as a prime important,
as more important than politics
and all other concerns in the life
and the few are much less
about class consciousness
than the older generations
during their own generations
experience in the 60s and 70s.
Although to remind us,
these generations were
actually the Rad children
who in fact grew up in the high mountains
in 1970s and the 60s,
and yet they were also the
generation who rejected
this whole conception
of class consciousness.
And at the official level,
we can see that there's
a new discourse of family
as a foundational political order.
So first Deng Xiaping's idea of Xiaokang
as the goal of China's modernization.
So basically, it reflects
what the grasses opinion
has been calling for and articulating for
almost five to four
years in the middle 70s.
It also reflect well balanced articulation
that each families sell,
and basically the foundation
of the national body politics.
So these are another two
lignite found family letters
that shows what kind of political
opinions that people felt
about the situations from
a Shanghai sent-down youth
who were strangled in Anghuei,
and basically he was promoted
to a factoring company,
but never returned to
Shanghai until the middle 80s.
So just you said he was
writing to his fiancee,
political struggles are simply
meaningless struggles for powers
and the grassroots class
must have their own opinion
of every issue based
our clear understanding
of all self interest.
And then I used to
consider myself a Marxist
and indeed read Marx and Lenin,
but since he are always
beyond the explanations.
So after so many years of struggle,
the conclusion that reached this act
is actually that there are supreme ideal
in an highest happiness in life
is not the communist visions,
but the witness in their
baby our best qualities.
Let him realize our dreams and
stand tall among his peers.
So we can see this kind
of competitive parenthood
is already bubbling in
the grass root mindset
by the late 70s.
So what is the nature of Xiaokang society?
First is a de-politicization,
it means the end of mass politics
as a consistent state
strategy and ideology,
and then it also means a
more natural base of power.
So the communist regime
was no longer based on
communism and division,
but actually effectively
based on parental care
and the sacrifice for the children.
It also means a new
ideology of development
as a family wealth accumulation,
so the family can share the wealth
and can see the futures in
the national environment.
And ultimately, it means
the family as a new unit
of bottom up mobilizations
through intergenerational sacrifice.
So basically continues the
revolution was still alive,
but only in terms of
economical mobilizations.
So in conclusion, the paradox
of revolution austerity
was that it basically ended
the Continuous Revolution
as Mao has proposed,
but at the same time it actually
transformed the family life
and made urban families the new dynamo
of economic mobilizations
in post-Mao China.
At the same time,
it transformed urban
family-state relations,
from the kind of pure
dominations and absorptions
into a class-based society
to a situation where the state
has to rely on mobilization
and sacrifice of families
in order for its economic development,
and finally I want to
highlight family letters
as a key source for studying
this kind of relations.
Thank you, and sorry for overtime.
- Hi, so I'll go ahead
an introduce myself,
my name is Denise Ho and I've been asked
to serve as discussant today.
So I will offer some brief remarks
and then we'll open up to general Q&A.
So firstly, just thank
you for the panelists
for including me in this
fascinating body of work.
I think I speak for others in the field
when I say that reading the
inspirational scholarship
of the next generation
of leading historians
is one of the most
rewarding parts of my job,
so thank you for reminding
me why I do what I do.
So as for the panelists in totality,
I think we can address
three common themes,
and the first theme is
going to be the largest,
and the second I'll give
a bit less attention to.
The first theme is that
the papers invite us
to revisit the economic history
of not only Mao's China and
afterward as the title suggests,
but also this longer arc
of what the economy meant
in modern Chinese history.
Second, I think all of
the papers invite us
to continue to pay attention to ideology
in our analysis of contemporary China.
And then finally, the papers remind us
to draw on a diversity of sources
and an increasing body of sources,
and Adam and Yanjie in particular
demonstrate what kind of work can be done
with new source spaces.
So first, the largest umbrella
revisiting the economic
history of modern China.
Under this, I have a first
category of economic experience
and the context for economic experience.
All four of the papers
are in their own way
about overturning previous assumptions
about economic activity
in the Mao era and after,
or in the Mao era and its
transition to the reform era.
Adam makes a convincing argument
that entrepreneurship
persisted in socialist China,
that it was far larger in
scale and more extensive
than had been claimed to quantify it,
it crossed administrative boundaries
and it was tacitly permitted
by local officials,
an attitude he suggests
was known to the people
engaging in entrepreneurship.
Gavin shows how the service industry
persisted in Mao's China,
though in the 1970s the very
definition of service or fuwu
and the people it would serve
underwent a transformation.
Additionally, tourist service pivoted
from being an act of
revolutionary diplomacy
to one of modernization.
Yanjie's paper examines
how ordinary families
experienced the financial burdens
of the sent-down youth movement,
showing how essential state policy
resulted in shifting financial burdens
from the state to the family,
an economic cost that
created family debts,
created family tensions,
and ultimately lead to a turn
from revolutionary rhetoric
towards a primary concern
with a family's financial well being.
And then finally,
Peter's paper integrates a
history of management education,
a history of overseas Chinese investment,
and an analysis of how management
was theorized and taught
to create links between
the Mao era and after
and also between China,
or among China, Hong Kong,
and North American business schools.
Another category worth highlighting
under this larger umbrella
of economic history
is the role of geography.
So each of the papers has a
different geographic lens,
one that both widens and contracts.
In his paper, Adam takes his
data and visualizes on a map
showing how transactions
transcended geographic boundaries,
and perhaps retraced
historic trading networks
despite the Maoist ideal of autarky.
Gavin's paper also has
a geographic dimension,
and this aspect comes out even more so
in his upcoming dissertation
with its analysis of the railway workers
who serve on the
Guangzhou-Shenzhen railway line.
It is in this mobility
that his service workers
sort out the meaning of service
and the meaning of serving the people.
While Yanjie's paper starts
and ends in Shanghai,
he invites us to revisit our perceptions
of the urban-rural divide.
We could have conventionally
thought of sent-down youth movement
as one in which the state
offloads excess labor
and puts the burden on the countryside,
but here the burden is actually put back
on the family in the city
so it reframes our geographic thinking
about the sent-down movement.
And then finally, Peters
paper extends the analysis
of his recently published
book on Trans Pacific Networks
to this establishment of MBA programs
by American universities
and with the help of
elite Hong Kong graduates.
Another category worth thinking about
when we put all these
four papers side by side
is a category of periodization,
and all of the papers have an attention
to both the historical narrative
and the creation of that
historical narrative
in their perspective topics.
Adam does this in two ways:
he shows that entrepreneurship
persisted across 1949
and that the reform era entrepreneurship
was not released by the policies
of reform and opening up,
but was rather preceded by
a wave of entrepreneurship
that began in the mid 1970s.
Adam is also able to use data
to show how activity doesn't just decline
after so called socialist transformation,
but that it comes in waves
despite the interruptions and bureaucracy
created by the Cultural Revolution.
Gavin's research invites us
to think about periodization
by framing perhaps periods of
socialism and high socialism,
or a long and short Cultural Revolution.
Thus, the early 1970s for Gavin
is the beginning of a transformation
in the service industry,
one that also maps on to China's admission
to the United Nations.
Yanjie's paper periodizes is in two ways:
on a specific level, he links
the sent-down youth experience
with youth discontent in the years after,
so a transition periodization.
But on a longer time scale,
and this comes out more so in the paper
than in the presentation,
he connects a long history
of what Xiaokang meant
with Xiao Japing's
reformulation of Xiaokang
for the era of reform.
And finally, Peter's study
of management education
particularly in a paper,
a close reading of the textbook
industrial enterprise management
shows how the history of Mao
era scientific management
was rewritten for the age of
educating a new generation
of managers and entrepreneurs.
Under this larger category
of economic history,
I want to mention two other
sub categories briefly
in the interest of time.
Related to the category
of geographic space,
there's a theme of connections
with the world outside of China
highlighted particularly
in Gavin and Peter's work.
And secondly, an important theme
in the study of economic history,
there's this idea of family
and intergenerational relationships,
something that Yenjie's just
paper calls our attention to.
That is if one aspect of
Chinese business history
is the role of the corporate family,
and if Mao era policies have been seen
as disrupting family networks
or families strategies,
Yanjie shows us how families
continued to strategize
as a family to maximize
their economic well being
in the Mao period.
The second category or the second theme
is the importance of ideology.
I want to underscore how all these papers
demonstrate the continued
importance of using ideology
to analyze the experience of
Chinese socialism and after.
For Adam, ideology is
one of the entry points.
He can trace the reoccurrences
of speculation and profiteering
in the People's Daily,
and then he can show how despite
rhetoric to the contrary,
local officials did not prosecute cases
in a way that reflected the rhetoric.
For Gavin, the ideological
tension of service work
is something that his historical actors
have to grapple with.
And throughout his paper
and throughout the longer dissertation,
he traces the political meaning of tourism
and the tourist industry.
For Yanjie, the research
question is to understand
the ways in which popular
sentiments shifted,
and how ideological slogans
reflected such sentiments.
And for Peter, in his own words,
the existence of the MBA programs,
quote, seemed to pose a paradox
and the ideological acrobatics
of the management text
becomes a way to explore
the meaning of management
in the era of reform.
And then finally,
as Yanjie did at the
end of his presentation,
I wanna highlight the use of new sources
and applaud the panelists
for their research methods.
Each in their own way is doing
a form of grassroots history,
an aggregation of personal experience
from the Shanghai family,
to the rural entrepreneur,
to the railway worker, to the MBA student.
In particular, Adams work
calls for the building
of micro data sets from grassroots data,
so I urge you to read the paper
if it's publicly available,
and also to watch his presentation
for the Stanford car conference
on Chinese archives in crisis.
So data and mapping becomes
increasingly important
in thinking about new directions
for contemporary Chinese history.
And finally, Yanjie's paper
makes exceptional and pioneering work
with Mao era personal letters
providing an intimate glimpse
into both family relationships
and even a history of family emotions
and secondly the mentalities
of the reform era experience.
So in the interest of time,
I'm only going to ask a couple questions
out of each panelist
and I'm sure many more
will come out in the Q&A.
So, Adam, I already got to
ask you a series of questions
after the Stanford conference
so perhaps you can indulge me
by thinking about a
more technical question.
So when I was reading your
analysis of the local officials
on page 25 and 26 of the paper,
I was thinking about
things like customs
violations and smuggling.
So if you read, let's say,
customs gazetteers from the 1990s,
their descriptions of what goods
were still able to pass through customs
if they were illegal
because they were needed.
So one case of this is pharmaceuticals.
So customs officials
would look the other way
if there was a particular
medicine that was scarce in China.
And as I was listening
to your presentation,
I was thinking about some
archival documents I've seen
where you have purchased
priceless at customs
with often things like small
electronic goods and so on
that the customs officials are buying
from travelers who are bringing in
more than they're allowed to bring in.
So in your analysis, is this parallel
to local officials treatment
of entrepreneurship,
or are imported goods to be understood
in a different category?
In one of your final slides,
you showed how agriculture
and consumer goods
were not punished in the
same way as other items.
So could we look at these
customs imported goods
in that same vein?
A second question for Gavin.
So I just kind of by coincidence,
I read your paper right
after Peter's paper
and so I wanted to ask you
more about tourism textbooks
in tourism education.
I noticed that in your presentation
you showed us a photograph
of a handbook for tourism workers.
And so thinking through Peter's analysis
of management education,
can you tell us more
about tourism education
and how it changed in your period
for the presentations today
and perhaps even after?
When did schools of tourism appear
and do they have any parallels
to other forms of education
in the reform era transition?
For Yanjie, I was hoping
to ask you a methodological question.
One of the things you did
really well in the paper
is to link the very
different kinds of sources.
On the one hand, you showed us slides
where you were aggregating
data from labor gazetteers,
but then when you look
at the family letters,
especially in your paper,
these are really about
intimate family relationships
and emotions and conflicts
within the family.
So I wanted to ask you about
what are the methodological
opportunities and challenges
of dealing with very, very
different kinds of data?
And then finally, Peter,
you ended your paper
with a number of questions
that you hope to answer
in the future.
To follow up on your conclusion,
I was thinking of two questions.
One of them was have
you found out more since
about the ways in which
textbooks were written?
My ignorant understanding
of MBA training in the U.S.
is that it's based on this case method,
so was this way of teaching
adapted to the Chinese context and how?
What kinds of businesses
were used as cases
when one was studying
in management in China?
And then as a second question,
your conclusion got me thinking
about financial journalism.
So does financial
journalism develop in tandem
or after management education?
Do you find similar ties with Hong Kong?
I'm thinking about economic reporting
coming out of South China, for example.
What's the justification and theory
of financial journalism
which is often seen as something
that pushes the envelope
on reporting in contemporary China?
So perhaps what we can do
is invite each panelist
to respond to these questions
or the discussant comments,
and then we'll gather some of the Q&A
that I'm seeing popping
up in the Q&A function.
- And thank you, Denise,
for this really generous
and insightful comments.
I think we can start with maybe Gavin
and then we go around in the same order.
- Thank you, Yanjie,
and thank you, Denise,
for those comments.
I think first of all to
answer your specific question
about the tourism training,
I had the good fortune
to spend a year in China
doing fieldwork as sort
of a visiting student
at one of the tourism schools
at Sun Yat-sen University in Guangzhou.
And, of course, what the
students there are studying
is a much higher level
about sort of the sociology
and economics of tourism,
and not sort of so much
the practical training.
But we definitely see
in kind of roughly around the time
in the four modernizations,
the late 1970s,
we see in Shanghai and
Beijing and Guangzhou,
the first sort of like practical
tourism training schools
coming into being,
and I think the first model,
and the first model for many
sort of things in China,
in the new China, is the
sort of the Soviet model.
And so in the 50s and
even to the early 60s,
we see much of the learning
about how to do the business of tourism
coming from the sort of
the model of interest
which existed in the Soviet
Union since the 1920s.
And after the sort of the Soviet model
is no longer sort of is now revisionist,
a lot of the training initially,
a lot of the circulation of knowledge
is really through direct observation,
it's sort of seeking truth from facts,
it's a direct observation
of the tourists themselves.
And so guides are taking notes
not just on the sort of
the reactions of tourists
to sort of like the political
reactions of tourists,
but also on their reactions to service
and like trying to learn directly
from the reactions of foreign tourists.
And I mean, I think finally
what we see in the 70s and 80s,
and this, I think, really relates
to what Peter talked about,
is we really see the
importance of Hong Kong,
because Hong Kong was always
sort of the entry point
for tourists into China.
I mean, the vast majority of
tourists are coming into China
from Hong Kong,
and the vast majority of the tourists
are residents of Hong Kong.
And so we're seeing a lot of
learning coming from Hong Kong,
we're seeing like in the early 80s
hotels in Shanghai are sending
chefs to Hong Kong hotels
to train there also.
The early, particularly
as China's tourism grows,
the main constraint is the lack of hotels.
And so the Hong Kong investors
sort of play a really critical
role in financing hotels,
and also in designing and
managing those hotels.
So I mean, that's what I would say
to that specific question.
You give me so many other
things that I could talk about,
I don't wanna take too
much time from the others.
But one thing I do
wanna want to highlight,
which I didn't really get a chance
to sort of highlight so
much in my talk today
'cause of the time constraints
was really the role of gender and service,
and I think that relates to the economics
of tourism as well.
I mean, people, particularly men,
do not want to be service workers,
that's primarily because
they see it as women's work
and they say it's a
sector dominated by women
and they repeated the complain
about how it sort of damages
their marriage prospects.
So, and I mean, that goes for the men,
but even women engaged in service industry
really see it as a dead end,
it's an unskilled labor.
So as this, and I think this also adds
to what Yanjie was talking about,
as we have more and more sort of youths
coming back into the urban
workforce in the late 70s,
we have to sort of funnel more
of them into service trades,
and that sort of sectors
really doubles in employment
from 1970 to 1982.
So there's a lot of new ways
to sort of try to make it
more acceptable to people,
and one of the ways
is through sort of
professionalization of it.
And I think that sort of that ideology
of professionalization really
does feed into how we justify,
how do we reconcile
people's sort of aspirations
with the reality of the
labor market at that time?
Thank you.
- Thank you so much for those
great questions and comments,
and try do them in the reverse order.
The financial journalism is something
I have not thought about at all.
So that's really interesting.
As to the intellectual and
potential personnel links there,
thinking about magazines
or other publications
like Xai Jing and their origins
and the kind of knowledge
that you would need to have
in order to pursue financial journalism,
but I really don't know
that much about that aspect of it
and that's a new avenue to go down.
The textbooks is really interesting,
because, and there's a lot going on there,
because I think that industrial
enterprise management
was the textbook in the Chinese language
for a lot of the 1980s.
It goes through a ton of editions.
I haven't gotten my hands
on all of the additions
and it seems to be a prestigious thing
to be appointed to the council
that's writing the textbook,
and they're selecting a
kind of expanding number
of co-authors to revise the
various editions of this text.
But then when we get to the 90s
and the partnership and the
transition towards MBA programs,
there's this interesting
kind of bifurcation
because in particular the
programs at Fudan and Tsinghua
pride themselves on being in English,
and the textbooks they continue to use
are primarily the exact
same textbook as MIT
or other programs,
the managerial communications
textbook being one example
or "Data, Models, and Decisions".
But "Data, Models, and Decisions",
which I didn't go into too far,
has a number of translations
some which seem to be authorized,
and some of which seem to be unauthorized.
And the whole point of
data models and decisions
is to work through specific cases.
So the involved faculty have talked about
in the authorized translations,
they have begun to
choose new Chinese cases
that are more closely tailored
to what students will anticipate
and experience in the future,
but oftentimes, the translation
is just an exact translation
of the English version.
So there's similarly more
work that I can do there,
some which goes out of my timeframe,
this is the last chapter of the project
so we'll see where I end up.
But thank you, both of
those are great avenues
to continue researching on.
- So maybe Adam?
- Sorry.
Yeah, no, that's an interesting question
about the goods that are
being smuggled through
and then like the
permissibility of those goods,
I think we can treat
them the exact same way
as the other types of
goods that I'm looking at.
So one thing I'm doing
with my data set right now
is that I've taken all of the goods
that have been seized by officials,
and I'm organizing them into
the classification systems
that were created by government officials,
so class one, class two,
and then class three goods.
And then in that we also have
which administrative departments
oversee the management
of particular types of goods,
like the grain department's over grain,
and then cotton's control,
but anyway so on so forth.
And I'm looking at how these
different types of goods
are variably controlled in the economy,
I think we can do the exact same thing
with the custom networks.
Yeah, I'll stop there.
I wanna answer some of the questions
that people have brought up
so I'll leave time for that.
- Thank you, Denise, for
this wonderful question.
It's actually a very challenging one
so I will seek to provide
my very humble opinion
on this methodology question.
I think with the current
political situations,
it become increasingly difficult
really to secure a complete set of sources
that goes all the way from provincial
or even central level archives
to grassroots sources.
And increasingly, we need to
rely on grassroots sources
that we have no direct control actually.
So here basically work on
what we can stop sometimes.
So there's definitely
some kind of challenges.
So my approach to this question is that
first is we need to look
at grassroot sources
as a new type of challenge
to the historic profession
because it raises new ethical
questions about the use.
So the most urgency are actually
for grassroots historians,
especially for people like me
who are working private sources
is that what kind of protocols,
privacy protocols that we need to adopt
in order to protect privacy of the,
I'll say the letter writers or the diarist
or some people will have some
petitioners to the work units.
The second question
is the basic or immediate
challenge, of course,
sources that is often
incomplete, scattered,
and sometimes extremely idiosyncratic.
I think Adam did a fabulous job
of compiling almost a whole
data set from two companies,
but that's very rare
among grassroots works
because most people don't have this,
sometimes you just don't have
this complete collections.
So the question is how to
work with more scattered,
sort of more scattered nature,
and my experience is that
we need to keep in mind
the question of scale
and the question of
information bureaucracy,
that is how the kind of informations
we gathered from grassroot sources
reflect only certain issues,
or certain aspects of certain
issues at a certain locale.
So we need to contextualize
it really carefully
with sources from
archives or other sources,
or macro data.
And then we need to bear in mind
that it's really a very small piece
of the whole information system,
that is like churning out
millions of documents,
private and public, every day.
So basically, we need to like
piece up the jigsaw puzzle
to know where are the missing puzzles,
and where our information
will actually contribute
to the kind of larger information network
that was operating in Mao's China.
So that's my answer
and I'll keep on thinking
about your question later.
Thank you.
I see we had a lot of questions.
- We have a lot of questions
and about 20 minutes remaining.
So maybe what we can do
is have a first tranche
of two questions per speaker
that you can answer as you wish
and then we can go to a
second round of questions
if we have time.
So let's see, Peter,
I'm mostly choosing in the
order in which they came in.
You have a question from,
scrolling through here,
you have a question from Coji
Hirata and Isabella Jackson.
Isabella asks, can you please tell us more
about the students in these MBA programs?
And Coji asks, I assume
many of the students
in management education
were employed by SOEs
rather than private enterprises,
did the still dominant
presence of SOEs in China
influence the content of MBA
education in a substantial way?
Also, were these programs related
to Zhu Rongji's SOU reform
in any way?
So let's do two questions for Peter.
Two questions for you Yanjie,
we have one from Sarah Chang.
The question has to do with
state-family relations.
Scholars in the socialist period
sometimes characterize the connection
between state and family
as a mutual embeddedness
where the family was a smaller cell
within a larger production regime,
would you say this relation
is radically different
in a Xiaokang society?
Does the family break out of
this relation with the state?
What bearing does this
have on contemporary China?
And a second question from Coji,
Coji Hirata, is the youngest
vision of Xiaokang society
related to the one
child policy in any way?
Then let's see two questions for Adam.
I don't know if Adam you
would prefer to choose them,
or go with the first two that came in?
- Either is fine.
- Okay, well, if we go with
the first two that came in,
we have one from Huanjajo.
I wonder if you tried
to look for these people
engaged in such activities
or their relatives
to learn more about how being caught
in the practice of illicit
entrepreneurial activities
may have influenced their life,
was there any non-formal punishment
such as a loss of reputation?
And you also have an early
question from Aaron Glassman.
Is there a difference
between a local official
who corruptly profits on local
violation of socialist policy
and a local official who
fosters entrepreneurship?
And there's a longer question
but the wrap up question is,
why isn't this just a story
about local corruption?
What does your research have to say
about rule of law in the PRC?
And I don't have an
audience question for Gavin
so maybe I'll take the chairs prerogative
and ask you about the role
of the China Travel Service
which comes up in your dissertation
and you're able to discuss at length.
So I think that for many of us
who study or travel in China,
we encounter the China Travel Service
in our own going around.
And so I wondered if you
would talk more about
the history of that
as a private and bureaucratic institution,
and then when does the emergence
of private or local
travel agencies appear?
Shall we?
Sure, we'll start with Peter.
- Sorry, I didn't know.
And thank you to the audience
members for these questions
that kind of overlap
so I think I'll just kind of
take them together, I think,
in terms of the students
in that there's this really
interesting evolution
in the nature and origin of
the students in these programs,
and that as the questions
implied that in the 1980s,
you really aren't talking about primarily
state-owned enterprise and party managers
of various divisions and
pieces of the bureaucracy
and state industry,
many of whom are being assigned be pei fu
to these programs,
for sometimes it's just two weeks
for what we would probably
call an extended conference
or something along those lines
to wholesale one years or two years
of re-education of various kinds.
What's interesting there, though,
is there does not seem
to be a particular link
between who the students were in the 1980s
and the nature of the content
that they're being given.
And that I do not have as
many syllabi and curriculum
such as I would like,
but that a lot of the
time what is being taught
seems to be determined more by
the various forms of partners
and partnerships that are
structuring these programs.
And so a good example is
that the Yijibu program
be it with Battat mostly
in the the commanding role
is largely copying MIT's MBA
program from the beginning.
The Shanghai Municipal Program,
which the students are
very much being assigned
from city enterprises in our
mid level career officials,
is being, in part, run
by the Chinese University of Hong Kong
by a person who was actually involved
in the China Travel Service before 1949.
So that's an interesting link,
which we can talk about, Kevin,
and the Beijing Municipal Program
is being, in part, run by a
Swedish management institute.
So in the 80s, at least,
there seems to be this whole smorgasbord
of different things going on
that are not necessarily correlated there.
For the MBA students,
that Isabella's question,
assuming we're really
talking about the 90s,
I don't have a lot of firm data about 1991
when the programs open
to 1997 when the MIT partnership starts,
we have a ton of data for after 1997
because in large part
MIT strongly encourages Fudan and Tsinghua
to launch career development centers,
and those career development
centers keep track
of the students, who they
are, and what they go on to.
And as Denise will know from the paper,
part of what I think is
just really interesting
is that one of the
things they kept track of
is what the students made
before, not in terms of money,
before they entered the program
and what they make after the program
and that they experienced huge pay rises
as the MBA students graduate
and largely join
multinational corporations
and foreign joint ventures in China.
So with the foreign
structured MBA programs,
you see this interesting
demographic of people
who are aspiring, it seems,
or being scaffolded towards careers,
very different careers in multinationals
and joint ventures after these programs,
very different from the
1980s of people being pei fud
into these programs.
- I'm I next?
- Sure.
- Okay, great.
Yeah, so just to answer the question,
so I've interviewed dozens of
former government officials
who were in charge of prosecuting
illicit entrepreneurship,
and I've interviewed many
illicit entrepreneurs
who are engaged in these
underground activities
in these periods.
So through oral histories,
I'm trying to explore
more of those dynamics.
I was really fortunate to
interview for example, Xia Gonga,
who was the guy who started that the
(speaks in foreign language)
like the commodities market,
and he's like maybe the
first official in China
to really allow long
distance trade and commerce
at the local level prior
to reform and opening up.
So those kinds of interviews
are really get to explore
those dynamics a lot more.
So is this just a story of corruption?
I don't think so.
For one, what's particular
about my data set,
these are the cases of entrepreneurs
who are prosecuted by the state.
So in some way like all I
have is examples of failure.
These are the guys who got caught.
These are the guys
who did not successfully
bribe the officials.
These are the people that show
up in the historical record,
any really successful listed entrepreneur
is not part of written history, right?
I mean, they're just not going to be
in the documents produced by the state
prosecuting these individuals.
And furthermore, if corruption
was the leading story,
we wouldn't necessarily expect to find
strongly pattern activity.
So we would expect that
the bribery would be
idiosyncratic to the individual,
to the relationships,
and things like that,
what I find in my data
sets is highly calculated
and patterned forms of prosecution.
You see that officials
irrespective of who is being prosecuted,
prosecute some types of
activities a lot more than others,
and so that's a really important story
that I'm trying to tell.
And I got several questions,
a lot of them deal with
what was the nature of entrepreneurship?
How big was it?
How long did it carry on for?
So in my dissertation project,
I look at the persistence
of entrepreneurial activity
from the very start of like
the socialist high tide,
all the way to reform and opening up.
And what I find is these
practices are ubiquitous,
they're not contained to
particular regions of China
and they persist throughout
the whole period.
So right in the Great Leap Forward,
there is tons of listed
entrepreneurial activity
which I'm dealing with in the
chapter I'm writing right now.
And someone asked me
what am I doing different
than the existing accounts
of entrepreneurship
on the master?
There are existing accounts
of entrepreneurship
in this period,
but I would say a couple things,
one, the existing accounts
really focus on the socialist
transformation period,
mostly, the really good stuff.
Robert Kleiber has some
amazing work on this,
a number of individuals as well,
but a lot of it really stops at 1958.
After that, we do get some accounts,
but they're really heavily biased
toward Shanghai and Wenzhou,
like the experiences of
those particular place,
so they're very idiosyncratic
and they really don't tell us much
about the overall picture for China,
the relationship between
entrepreneurs and the state.
So that's what I'm
trying to do differently.
I am building these micro data sets
to give us a sense of like
the full scale of this.
So in the paper that I just presented,
I did 2500 cases that
were from two counties.
Why those two counties?
Just simply because I was lucky enough
to come across really complete collections
of documents for those two counties.
But in total, I have more than
8000 cases from across China
which I'm building into the data set,
but I have to figure out
how to deal with that data
because we have all different
kinds, it's incomplete,
so we have to figure out how
to deal with potential biases
and things like that.
So I'm working on that.
But I think we can also use
the type of data that I'm
creating in novel ways
to really get at other
measures of how ubiquitous
and systemic elicit entrepreneurship is.
For example, one thing
I'm working on right now
is I'm using price differentials
as a measure of the perceived risk
of illicit entrepreneurial activity.
So the best kind of way I can think of
to figure out how systemic,
as I said, again, my
datasets cases of failure.
So what size of all cases possible cases
did those represent?
That's a really, really
tough question to get at.
One way that I think I'm
gonna try to get at it,
is to use the reported price differentials
in the price that elicit
good like ration coupons,
cloth rations, grain rations,
how much they sold for and how
much they were purchased for.
Now, theoretically,
at least this is what's going
through my mind right now,
if we look at the differential in that gap
between the purchase and sale price,
entrepreneurs theoretically
would be calculating in
the potential risk of seizure.
I mean, these goods have like
zero transportation costs,
they're super immutable,
it's almost like cash.
So like the main thing
that would be going through
entrepreneurs minds when
they're buying and selling
in terms of profit calculations
is how likely am I to get caught?
And what I have found so far
in the analysis of all these
things is that spread is tiny.
They were, for example,
selling cloth rations
for maybe 50 cents a yard,
and then they were buying
them for 48 cents a yard.
It's a tiny differential
which implies that their
expectations of getting caught
and getting all of those things
ceased is relatively low.
And then there's other
cost too and things,
but if we attribute that
spread only to risk,
we can still get a sense
that this illicit economy
and from that we can
then estimate backwards
maybe how many people were
operating in this space.
So that's the kind of gist of
the thing I'm trying to do,
provide a very quantitative,
robust, rigorous way
of getting at the totality
of entrepreneurial activity
in the economy.
And then, of course, in
addition to deep readings,
individual case studies, oral history,
the stuff that is much more robust
in the current existing literature.
- Okay, so great questions.
So the first question
about these embarkness
of Chinese family state
I think you got a point
about a very crucial issue of foundation,
I will argue a fundamental issue
about the Chinese conception
of the state which are right,
and it's state family.
So according to the Confucian tradition,
and especially according to
the traditional Nietzsche,
where the concept of
Xiaokang really came about,
family and state were
continuous and inter embodied.
So first, you started with
the family as foundation
like a pre-order.
And there's no like big boundaries
between what is conceptually family
and what is conceptually distant
like in Aristotle's politic.
So what happens after the Mao's revolution
was, in fact, I argued in my dissertation,
a sort of a return to this
conventionalized ideal
of the family state,
rather than what happened
during the Great Leap Forward
which I termed as a state family,
that is to reduce family to the dependence
or eventually eliminate the family, right?
So the individuals who belong
to this biggest communist society.
So basically what happened
after the Mao's revolution, interestingly,
is a return to more of Confucianism norm,
and that never happened in Eastern Europe.
And that's a very big reason
why China actually survived
the Jun force, right?
Is because of this fundamental
ideologies of Xiaokang
that has tied in with
China's old traditions
of more commercialized
embodied family state,
and a full question of one child policy.
In fact, the most interesting
thing about one child policy
was that is the continuation
of these austerity measures
of family planning
which started as part and parcel
of this austerity measures in the 60s
that were actually put forward
to deal with the fallout
of Great Leap Forward.
So what happened was that
while all other measures
cease to practice because they
were extremely ideological,
more ideological, ideologically embodied,
this one child policy,
this family planning,
were only strengthened and
indeed institutionalized
to it's extreme form as one child policy
in post Mao's China.
So what happened was that
there was a change in context
and political interpretations
of this policy
from a anti-crisis measure,
so from austerity measure
to a new discourse of state development.
So basically, it actually helps.
I mean, so the basic justification
was that having less babies,
having less child was a
boon to the family welfare
because to reduce the cost
and eventually will lead to
better economic development
that will benefit families.
So it very much ties within
this big concept Xiaokang
as modernization economic development,
but it was not initially so
when it was first
conceptualized in the 60s.
Thank you.
- Okay, thank you, Denise,
for the excellent question.
I'll go relatively quickly
I know we're short on time.
Basically there's two agencies
that are sort of responsible for tourism,
for inbound foreign tourism
in China during this period,
one is the China
International Travel Service,
which hosts quote, unquote,
sort of foreign tourists,
The other is the Overseas
Chinese Travel Service
which hosts musically overseas
Chinese and many Hong Kong
and Macau compatriots.
Of course, not every tourist to China
comes through one of these agencies,
there's a variety of organizations
in China during this time
that host foreigners and
take them to sightsee.
One thing that I think I wanna underscore,
particularly regarding the
economic aspects of tourism,
is that for every tourists hosted
by the China International Travel Service,
basically every sort
of European, Japanese,
other Western tourists,
there are probably 10 tourists
hosted by the Overseas
Chinese Travel Service.
And so economically, the
Overseas Chinese Travel Service
is always the more important agency
even though in a lot of the
sort of the travelers accounts
we see a lot more about
the China International Travel Service,
and particularly, we see a lot
about the sort of the
frustrations about how this agency
it sort of prevents people
from traveling to places they want to go.
But all that being said
despite having these sort of two
sort of overarching agencies,
their operations are
very, very decentralized,
and so they're each branch
office in a particular city
is really sort of staffed locally
and is sort of taking some
sort of broad direction
from the head office,
but it's really like it's up to themselves
to sort of like manage their finances
and manage their program.
And so that's why I think we
see in the Cultural Revolution,
and I think this sort of is how I'll segue
to, I think, Sarah, China's question
about the periodization.
In 1969, the head
offices of these agencies
get shut down in Beijing but
the branches still continue,
so the branches are still operating
throughout the Cultural Revolution.
And so in 1971 when there's
this sort of decision
from top leadership
that we can make some money from tourism,
the branches are really pretty quickly
able to sort of to kick to
step into gear and host people.
And I mean, I think part
of that decision in 1971,
it's a very practical decision,
but I think it's also related
to the Cultural Revolution.
We've seen that we've
hosted a lot of people,
the Chinese government says
we've hosted a lot of people
to come during the Cultural Revolution
and people are really drawn
to China during that period,
they want to see the
revolution that's going on.
And so this is a chance finally
that there's a sort of real realization,
we don't have to foot the
bill for all these people,
a lot of these people are willing to come
and pay their own way
and this is a chance for us
to sort of to make some money
from hosting these people.
So there's always a political element
and an economic element,
but there's this realization in 1971
that we can earn some money
even as we sort of educate people
as to sort of what our vision
of sort of socialism is,
and what our vision of the new China is.
- Thank you for that.
so we are at time,
but I've been corresponding
with the panelists in the chat
and I think that consensus is we're okay
with going a few minutes over
since there's still a number of questions
that didn't get addressed.
So if those of you who need
to go in the participants
are welcome to go,
but I think as a chair I'll
exercise that prerogative
and extend us for about 10 minutes
since we're not at HA,
no one is going to push
us out of the room,
and this is Hernanda to get
us all together in one space.
So perhaps we can do one more
question or one more comment
from each panelist as
a way of wrapping up.
Adam, you have a rather long list
of five or six other questions
that haven't gotten answered.
So if you wanna choose one
or two of those to address
and a final concluding remark,
you're welcome to do that.
Yanjie, you got a question in the chat
that I know you answered
to the individual,
but maybe you could
answer it to the group.
Mark Levine asks, did you
come across any instances
where sent-down youths
wanted to stay in rural areas
contrary to the majority?
What reasons would have considered
contributed to this desire,
ideological, familial, et cetera?
Gavin, I think you've just answered
Sarah's question verbally.
So if there's anything
else you want to add
by way of conclusion, please do so.
And then, Peter, I think I'm not seeing
a final wrap up question
for you in the Q&A
so maybe I can ask a final
question for your paper.
As you were showing all of those
screenshots of the campuses
and that people standing around,
I was thinking about
the architecture of MIT
and the architecture of Tsinghua,
so they're based on each other as a model.
And so I wondered about
longer institutional links,
was this something that
was either called upon
in the building of these schools,
or if these longer institutional links
were something that were invoked
in the commemorative materials
that you were using in your research.
Another way of asking this question is
in your paper in the presentation,
you looked at the Hong Kong alums
and these Chinese American alums,
were there any Chinese alums
of an earlier generation
that were part of this MBA
or the management education
as you've started to research it?
- Do you want me to go then in that order?
Okay, sure.
Yeah, so I think there's
a lot of great questions.
I'm sorry, I can't answer them all.
I think I'll answer Ron Byrd's question
and he asks, from an archival concern,
what has been the fate of
these documents you discovered
on your research?
Is there a common fate
of PRC archival documents
to be discovered in private hands?
Great question.
So there's this whole kind
of school of literature
that is sometimes referred
to as sinological garbology,
although I don't really like that term.
But it was really I
think Michael Schoenhals
was really one of the kind
of leaders in this field,
and beginning in the 1990s
he started going around
to these flea markets just as I've done,
and buying a lot of
former government archives
that had slipped into private circulation.
So during the 1980s in China,
there was this massive purge of archives
as the various government
institutions were being merged,
and at the time, there were
paper shortages in China.
So instead of just burning the
documents or scrapping them,
the archivists were instructed
to turn over these documents
to paper pulpers who would
theoretically recycle them,
but then somewhere between the archivist
and the paper pulper,
someone decides to like sell
them into private circulation.
So there are enormous quantities
of local government archival materials
still in private circulation today.
And you see many scholars
and institutions now,
particularly because of the
recent archival closures
in China in the past few years,
there's been a lot of people
that have been working to
recollect these documents
and then assemble private
and institutional archives.
So Yanje is a prime example,
the archive he worked with,
is at Fudan started by John Latian,
it's a really massive collection
of all different kinds
of really interesting materials
that he acquired from local villages
in the Guangdong and Guangzhou area.
But then there's scholars in Europe
that are doing the same thing,
Michael Schoenhals, Daniel
Lees, in particular,
are leading this Stanford University
and the Hoover Institute
are trying to actively
procure these materials.
So there is a collective effort
among certain persuasion
of historians today
to go and reconstitute
these local archives
in order that we can continue to promote
future historical research
in the face of shrinking archival access.
But as Yanjie mentions, there's
ethical concerns with this,
how do we do this appropriately?
How do we protect the
source of our sources?
privacy of the individuals
mentioned in the sources?
And I think for all of these concerns,
personally, I think we
should adopt the practice
of like anthropologists and journalists
and just go for full anonymity
and like we need to
rethink how as historians
we engage in citation practices,
how we make these materials
available to other people,
but for example, I myself
am trying to fully digitize
my collection and then make it available
to the academic community
after some kind of
privatization of the materials
to protect the anonymity
of the people mentioned.
But I think this is a
really important effort,
and I hope other historians will join in
and make it possible to continue
preserving these documents.
- Just few words in addition to you items,
I totally agree with you about
the methodology challenges,
actually, we are, I mean, with
my collaborators in China,
we are also digitizing
the letter collections
and trying to make it into a textual form
where we can actually use textual analysis
or other more modern implements
even like machine learning
to study the Roderick
and the network's there.
So there are a lot of things going on.
I think we can have some exchanges later
on the latest developments.
So basically, I think grassroots stores
will be increasingly
important for our research,
and there are a lot of things on the table
for us to think about ranging
from privacy protection
to the kind of methodology
challenges of using them.
So for Mao's question
about who are those staying
behind sent-down use,
actually there are a number of them
but they were among the
very distinctive minority,
and eventually, they were
all urbanized, I think,
as far as I know but locally,
so basically they moved
to the local counties
or local cities rather than
going back to like big cities
like Shanghai and Beijing where
they were originated from,
and the big reason for
them to settle locally,
and I happen to discuss about this
in one of my dissertation
chapters about family reunion
was that they already
started their families,
and in the 70s, they
already started dating
and that was a big issue
because once she started that,
you basically embedded locally
and it's extremely difficult to extricate,
that's what they use.
And eventually, you have
to like forcefully lay down
your own plan and thought
more about your children,
and eventually, what happened was that
you are bounded there.
So that's what happened to most youth
who eventually settle down locally
and to become part of local society.
I think that's all I can offer
and thank you for the question.
- Gavin, do you have any
final questions or comments
you'd like to say to wrap up?
- I think one thing I'd like to talk about
is that you mentioned
sort of geographic aspect
of my research,
and I'd like to just talk about that,
and going forward is that here,
I think one sort of like
one thing we see going
throughout this is that
tourism is dependent on sort
of mobility and immobility.
And in this case, in sort of my research,
we see sort of the mobility of
people coming from Hong Kong
or coming from other overseas
to visit an immobile sort
of population in China
during the 1970s.
But of course now, I
mean, tourism in China
is very, very different.
The people studying tourism
and the students that I met
when I was in China who
are studying tourism
are not studying inbound foreign tourism,
they're studying outbound tourism
or they're studying domestic tourism.
And so in my research
I see tourists coming
and mainly centered on
Guangdong, Shanghai,
Guangho and Beijing,
and that sort of shifts in the 80s
to match sort of broader
array of destinations
are open to people,
and part of that is by state decree,
there's a certain destinations
that are open to people
now like many, many more,
but tourism today is
not about so much about
bringing foreign currency from outside
to sort of Guangdong and coastal China,
it's about taking the money
and the mobility of people
in Guangdong, and people
in Shanghai, and Beijing,
and coastal urban areas
and having them shift some of that income
to help develop sort of the hinterland,
whether it's Tibet, it's
Guangzhou, it's places like that.
So I think tourism sort
of always functions
with that tension of the
mobility of one population
and the immobility of another,
but it's a way of trying to sort of shift
the flow of currency of some
sort from one place to another.
- Thank you.
Peter, last word.
- You asked about the
architecture and the pairing
between MIT and Tsinghua as
you correctly diagnosed there,
that it was very much evoked
in this kind of superficial way
as this logical pairing makes
a lot of historical sense
because of our previous roots,
and in some sense, almost a healing
of re-establishing these
ties and these connections.
But as you sharply picked
up on part of my interest
and entry into this
was through the Hong
Kong elite connection,
and that people of the foreign tycoons
that I pictured there,
two of them, either their
father or grandfather
had gone to Tsinghua as
boxer identity students
and then on to MIT.
And that as very savvy operators
who would understand that
education is training
and that the kind of social capital
you can buy through
donations to institutions,
their agenda, I think, is
really interesting here
at a more critical and political reading
of what they're doing
rather than just the celebratory accounts
of multi-generational
educational patronage,
that instead kind of trying
to steer educational systems
in the mainland toward what
they think would be useful
in the future, in most
especially to themselves.
This is a somewhat roundabout way
of saying that part of my interest here
I think is I find MIT's
agenda absolutely baffling.
I find it fascinating
that they pursued this
in the way that they did
largely on pretty vague ideas
of what they were gonna get
out of it in terms of prestige.
But weird, interesting that I think
that the Hong Kong elite donors agendas,
they I get deeply anti-communist
and kind of very immersed
in this kind of high
transactional politics
of elite higher education
and what it can do
if that answers your question.
- Thank you.
So, again, I want to wrap up
and thank all of the panelists,
to Yanjie for organizing,
to Stephanie Kim and the Yale
Council of East Asian studies
for hosting us today.